a educação inclusiva precisa de você é
você mesmo
mas não se preocupe não é só de você
a educação inclusiva é aquilo que muitos
de vocês já conhecem a idéia de que as
crianças estudam e aprendem melhor
quando estão crianças com e sem
deficiência na mesma sala de aula
a educação inclusiva é um objetivo é um
ideal que ainda está muito longe em
muitas escolas de nosso país e de muitos
países mas ela é absolutamente
necessária porque ela traz a diversidade
a riqueza da humanidade para a sala de
aula e prepara melhor o aluno para isso
aqui para o mundo fora da sala de aula e
como todos os grandes desafios que temos
em nossa sociedade
não interessa se estamos falando de
saúde pública do nível de desemprego de
corrupção
a educação inclusiva ela a gente tem a
tendência a encontraram motivos únicos e
muitas vezes até simples pelo qual ela
ou qualquer desses problemas não são
solucionados
eu comecei assim também eu comecei
achando que a solução para a educação
inclusiva era tecnologia porque eu acho
que até que dá pra entender e eu quando
não tinha acesso à tecnologia e eu
estudava bastante e improvisava do jeito
que desce e eu consegui chegar eu acho
que 11º lugar numa sala com 43 alunos
entrei em termos de notas depois que eu
tive acesso à tecnologia e tecnologia
assistiva
ia pra quem não sabe que permite por
exemplo que um computador
leia o conteúdo da tela para quem é cego
e e em geral o que ela faz é ajudar a
você superar qualquer que seja sua
deficiência
bom depois que eu tive acesso à
tecnologia assistiva
em vez de 11º eu era o quarto
só que eu já estava na universidade e
era quarto nenhuma turma incluindo todos
os cursos de 904 alunos
então pra mim
a tecnologia foi uma revolução eu como
todo jovem um pouco preocupado com
desemprego em vez de ficar desempregado
e trabalha em uma onde eu trabalhei em
uma microempresa em uma agência das
nações unidas em uma multinacional e
assim por diante
então claro essa era minha resposta
simples tica para a educação inclusiva
mas será que é assim de simples nos anos
80 tem uma organização é na europa que é
responsável por apoiar e ajudar às cegas
de todo aquele país
eu não vou especificar mas eles têm
muito dinheiro eles têm conhecimento
sobre a cegueira e nos anos 80 eles
ficaram sabendo de uma tecnologia que a
gente informalmente chama de scanner né
sr
o scanner é aquele mesmo equipamento que
vocês já usaram para escanear
fotografias e é permitir que vocês
tenham a fotografia que estava em papel
em formato digital dentro do seu
computador
esse mesmo scanner quando ele está sendo
usado com o software correto o software
adequado ele pode ler livros para alguém
que a célula e essa organização achou
interessante até tem uma tecnologia foi
analisou o seu potencial e resolveu
claro este dinheiro resolveu não comprar
por quê
por que o scanner não conseguia ler
jornais
então vejam bem a lógica e um cego não
vou ter acesso a milhares ou até milhões
de livros de tudo não tem biblioteca
pública e privada porque o equipamento
não consegue ler jornais
então será que o único desafio que a
gente tem é tecnologia
outro outra explicação clássica não só
para o desafio da educação inclusiva mas
fá muitos dos nossos desafios né
é a cultura eu acho que até essa crise
regional porque estudei sociologia então
eu falar que cultura não é uma boa
explicação não é de se esperar mas é uma
explicação muito fraca porque a gente
usa cultura para explicar tudo a pessoa
jogando lixo na rua a pessoa fazenda
barbeiragem no trânsito com a questão da
corrupção é tudo culpa da cultura ea
nossa cultura é aquela coisa conveniente
porque ninguém é responsável pela
cultura somos todos
então de certa forma não é culpa de
ninguém não é fácil de se mudar mas o
que acontece ou mesma pessoa que está
ali jogando lixo na rua vai de turista
para miami e de um minuto outro sem
ninguém ter reprogramado cérebro dele né
porque ele está ele continua gostando
das nossas músicas preferindo as nossas
praias mas agora que ele está lá de
turista ele faz tudo bonitinho
então quando a gente fala cultura na
verdade não é cultura são os incentivos
são as multas que tem que ser
autosuficiente a fiscalização que tem
que ser sério né
mas então temos essa explicação cultura
e incentivos
mas será que é uma boa explicação
um país como estados unidos até vários
países na europa que a gente considera
países mais inclusivos
nos estados unidos o nível de desemprego
entre pessoas com deficiência é mais de
70% no nosso país é mais de 90%
mas será que a cultura lá sendo mais
inclusiva tá resolvendo o desafio
as estatísticas educacionais para quem
tem deficiência lá e aqui estão bem
abaixo da média de quem não tem
deficiência
bom se não é cultura qual é outra
explicação clássica que a gente dá para
aquelas coisas que deveriam acontecer
não acontecem ou acontecem apesar de
grandes obstáculos é a iniciativa do
indivíduo né ea gente vê todo dia das
notícias ou escuta de amigos histórias
de pessoas que superaram tudo e
conseguiram coisas extraordinárias
então eu estou de acordo a iniciativa do
indivíduo aquela força de vontade
isso é absolutamente essencial mas é
suficiente
quando nós estamos falando de um sistema
que se mais de 70% das pessoas
no caso de estados unidos em mais de 90%
das pessoas com deficiência aqui no
brasil estão desempregados que estamos
falando de um sistema que está quebrado
porque assim se é uma percentagem
pequena que não tá conseguindo atingir
os seus objetivos a tudo bem
faltou iniciativa pessoal né podemos
culpar o indivíduo beleza mas 70% 80 a
90 por cento não estão conseguindo aí o
problema é um sistema bom
é importante a gente lembrar que a gente
começou falando aqui até uma explicação
é que eu comecei pensando que era
tecnologia logo comecei a considerar a
cultura
logo a iniciativa
individual então qual é a receita mágica
eu acho que o primeiro elemento da nossa
receita é a gente quer avançar nesse em
todos os nossos grandes desafios sociais
é não procurar uma receita mágica está
porque é um problema complexo que não
vai ser um dois ou três pontos que vão
resolver os desafios que são específicos
para cada escola para cada aluno
então eu não estou aqui pra falar olha é
bem difícil
tchau não eu gosto de coisas práticas o
que a gente pode fazer para melhorar a
situação porque eu falei que defendia
que a gente precisava contar com você
com cada um de vocês porque assim as
grandes empresas quando ela quer
requerem melhorar a qualidade de seus
produtos
ou elas querem melhorar qualquer um de
seus processos o que elas fazem
elas fazem algo que não exige
conhecimentos avançados pelo menos para
começar o processo e é vocês já sabem
perguntar por que e é perguntar porque
não só uma vez mas no mínimo cinco vezes
então na prática o que quer dizer isso
vamos imaginar o aluno fernando ou
qualquer aluno cego ele não consegue
fazer a prova porque o número 1 é porque
a prova não está disponível em braille é
não está disponível em formato digital
não tem um computador com o software
leitor de terra que aliás eu recomendo
acham 23 há ou não tem o professor não é
gravou aquela prova no formato digital
para estar disponível naquele momento
segundo porque porque eu não sabe
braille
terceiro porque não tem aquele
computador
ela na hora que você começa a chegar lá
pro terceiro quarto quinto porque você
vê que estamos falando de um sistema
você saiu daquela coisa de receitas
mágicas onde você tem um dois ou três
itens os cinco itens oito itens que
solucionam todos os problemas porque
nenhum problema igual nenhuma pessoa é
igual à outra
então na hora que você fala e faz
aqueles porque você não só identifica a
situação específica que está sendo
enfrentada por aquele aluno aquele
professor aquele diretor mais cedo
começa a enxergar o sistema ao redor de
tudo tudo isso quando você chega lá pelo
quinto sexto porque você já entendeu que
não dá pra fazer nada sozinho nessa vida
aquele aluno vai precisar se esforçar
aquele professor professor vai precisar
de algumas orientações específicas para
aquele tipo de deficiência
então a gente começa a falar de
parcerias entre a escola e alguma ong
especializada na local que possa dar uma
assistência direta
estamos falando já em pensar em
políticas públicas adequadas aquilo em
um desses decisões orçamentárias e não
interessa se a escola pública ou
particular
no momento que a gente começa a fazer
perguntar esses português
a gente começa a ver que existem
elementos em vários níveis que
contribuem para aquela aquele obstáculo
enorme então a solução vai requerer é
vários elementos que vão variar de caso
a caso mas essa visão sistêmica que não
é mais simples tica ela vai permitir que
a gente comece a construir um sistema
que não vai ajudar só aquele aluno servo
naquela situação naquele ano esse
sistema vai começar a ser mais eficiente
em ajudar milhares de alunos
eu já vi uma moça cega liderando um
workshop no fórum econômico mundial
eu já vi cadeirante é desenhando um
sistema de fazer para fazer exercício
máquinas para usar em academias
totalmente computadorizadas
eu já vi uma pessoa jovem com
deficiência intelectual
usando o computador em seu trabalho eu
acho que vocês merecem ter essa riqueza
no seu dia a dia
há 30 anos eu tive a sorte de que a
diretora da minha escola
via as provas pra mim a sorte de que
meus pais compraram o equipamento que eu
precisava me desafiaram mas nós estamos
falando de mais de 10% da população
brasileira
nós estamos falando de uma montanha de
talento que hoje está sendo desperdiçada
não podemos deixar que esses 10% ou mais
dependendo da sorte
eu prefiro muito mais que a gente possa
contar com você que possamos contar com
todos nós
muito obrigado